I believe it's selfish to think as Elon
does or as many other people think that
because there's no God and because
they're ultimately in a universe with no
God you have to construct your own
meaning it may be just as real as my
meaning I'm not denigrating agnosticism
I actually think a true scientist should
be an agnostic not only could it be a
soul simulation which smacks of divine
inspiration and intervention but it
could also be that you know God has
started the universe and then he's gone
or she's gone or it's gone and that's
unfalsifiable I've always wanted to ask
you Nate you know what keeps you going
like what what is your like you face
Doom and Gloom like I've been counting
you started going daily you know in in
2020 in January 2020 when it was like
the Iran they killed some guy in Iran I
remember you going basically live this
is it you have a family what do you do
what do you do like what is your coping
mechanism how do you maintain uh you
know the cheerfulness along with the
perspicacity that you have and knowing
what what you know how do you maintain a
cheerful disposition and and and get
through life essentially can I ask you
that absolutely and you use the word
pers perspicacity which I think was uh
Andrew Tate my unmatched perspicacity he
has popularize that term anyways um no I
think it's just a matter of you know
making sure that uh my kids are
obviously a big role in that and just
you know we kind of goof around and
bring some levity to my day to kind of
balance things out exercise is of vital
importance but I've always been
fascinated with the end of anything you
know but in particular you know human
beings is to this potential Collision
Course that we're on right now with our
meeting our own existential demise
perhaps there's definitely a component
of self-development when it comes to
trying to think about how we would
navigate very difficult situations
there's probably some right of passage
stuff in there with respect to you know
the grid were to collapse you know who
do you who do you become in that
situation so there's definitely a
self-development component to all of
this which I think is perhaps missing in
our current society that for the most
part most people live their lives
throughout the city they never have to
forge for Food they'll never have to
challenge themsel in any way that we've
historically had to up until the this
point you know that's why I've sometimes
thought well maybe prepping in
survivalism is just some like
evolutionary hangup which needs to be
eventually gotten rid of so that we can
get to the next level of things but I
also think that it's vital that we
constantly are reminded of survivalism
and there's a role that it plays I think
in in navigating the future being aware
that there might be unintended
consequences of various Tech
technologies that emerge this is where I
might differ with a lot of more
optimistic people who don't like the the
alarmism they think that it it's
detrimental but I think that fear is
like a base emotion that is almost in
many cases been medicated out of the
population but it does serve a vital
function just to survive we need to be
fearful of the world but in order to
thrive obviously we have to go beyond
that fear and trust one another
I guess even understanding my own place
in the universe I'm comfortable with my
whatever you want to call my
spirituality agnosticism whatever is I'm
comfortable knowing that someday I'm
going to die anyways but for me it's
just fascinating to to contemplate you
know the potential downfall of
civilization for a myriad of reasons why
why do you watch the channel what what
is your motivation for preparedness what
what intrigues you about it at all you
know I have to say maybe I'll get
canceled for it but most of my
colleagues are are pretty weak they're
weak physically a lot of them and I'm
not like some Super Jock although you
know uh you know I can hold my own I
used to say I could beat any you know I
could beat Stephen Hawking and arm
wrestling you know that was my claim to
fame did you uh did you ever roll with
Lex I didn't roll with him but we uh I
hung out with him for about six hours in
his bachelor pad in uh in Austin to do
an episode of his podcast um I'm hoping
we will hoping I I will do that uh at
some point we'll we'll see but you know
when I when I watch the channel I think
about a couple things one is to uh
pregame and and have you know the ounce
of prevention potentially and the worst
thing that would be wrong as you said
you know is you'll have a bunch of you
know uh you'll have a bunch of
freeze-dried food lying around which you
could use and and you you know it'll
last forever basically you can pass it
on it's cool to have out you know have
tools to teach the kids that you know
they can get a little you know bird poop
on them they're not going to die uh and
that you can raise strong you know
strong men I think the you're not the
first person to compare me to Andrew
Tate if you could no I'm just kidding
you you're the first person to ever it's
just that word that's the only
similarity yeah perspicacity there is
this connotation on one hand you have
Andrew Tate on the other hand you have
my friend Jordan Peterson and uh and
those are the role models that young men
have okay um I don't think either one's
perfect you know I I I love Jordan and
and we're coming very I don't
necessarily need the 12 you know I don't
need to make my bed every morning like
I'm a 50 you know year old man like I've
achieved a lot but that doesn't mean
that some 18 19 20 year old guy same for
jao my friend Jacko willink lives uh not
too far from here I got his jao fuel
here you know get up 430 in the morning
and do your burpees and then you know
swim in the 60 degree POS I don't need
to do that okay I have other things that
I do but on the other hand I want to
give you know kind of these lessons to
my kids because
children are like uh are like the seeds
the you know survival Vault seeds you
don't know what's going to sprout out of
them sometimes but you want to put them
in and make them resilient so they can
take a cold win they can take a dry
summer we have here as well and the
point being the the notion uh that some
Preppers have and you've talked about
this uh Altman talked about Peter teal
who's a friend of mine sort of a friend
I mean I've spent a lot of time with him
I don't know Altman I'd love to talk to
him on the podcast if he's listening i'
love to talk to him because I like to
talk about things from a physics
perspective as you can tell I'm
concerned with what is knowable from not
just a physics itaku you know wormholes
black holes other kind of holes the guy
obsessed with uh but from the
perspective of what can we build to
learn about to test hypotheses to do
deduction which I don't believe AI can
do at least not yet uh that's a subject
for another time but uh getting back to
to sort of why why I I do what I'm doing
at least in this realm I don't believe I
believe it's selfish to think as Elon
does or as um um you know many other
people think that because there's no God
and because they're ultimately in a
universe with no God um that you have to
construct your own meaning it may be
just as real as my meaning I'm not
denigrating agnosticism I actually think
a true scientist should be an agnostic
because if you're you know purely an
atheist that means you're denying the
existence you're saying you know without
a shadow of a doubt no God exists um and
then agnosticism means it's unknowable
it doesn't mean like some days I believe
in God some days I don't no it means
it's unknowable which I believe it is
right because not only could it be a
soul simulation which smacks of divine
inspiration and intervention but it
could also be that you know God has
started the universe and then he's gone
or she's gone or it's gone so uh so that
and that's
unfalsifiable getting back to the to the
selfishness of the prepping community so
when I was with uh Peter teal spent a
week with him and and others in Italy uh
about six eight months ago and the guy
has uh you know a bulletproof Mercedes
Benz on like on standby it's you know
this is well known I'm not like spilling
the beans he has a jet it's on standby
and he's got domiciles in in all over
the the world but including you know
Malta and including uh the south island
of New Zealand and I said to him I said
Peter you know you're you're incredibly
wise but like how are you gonna get
there you know you're not a pilot right
so you're gonna get there so there's a
pilot he going to fly you that that guy
you our gal they got a family like how
how is all the money in the world going
to convince you to teleport you know
them to this scenario or here's another
thing Elon wants to die on Mars as I
said that means he's got 10 kids they're
not going to have a father with them for
at least two years I don't think he's
going to put little baby X on the
Starship you know at age five and cruise
out to Mars the kid could die you know
from exposure to to cosmic rays I mean
his life expectancy will be shortened
it's no doubt about it the brain
function diminishes there have been
studies on brain tissue in space if it's
it's a horrible environment uh long-term
exposure and then when you get to Mars
we don't they don't have the auroras
they don't have the magnetic field
protection that we have here the days
are different the days are the same
length but the the seasons are different
uh it's a very inhospitable world so he
wants to go there to extend Humanity
make it interplanetary I tell all these
guys Nate I say look you want
immortality but you're greedy because
you want to be there when immortality
happens but you have an opportunity to
be immortal
and that's by your children and I don't
just mean your biological children I
believe we all have ideological children
you have millions you know people that
you've influenced I have you know
smaller amount but but I'm influencing
people that's my mission what I'm doing
in a large way as an educator you can
teleport not your physical body but you
can teleport your value system to the
infinite future and I think that's such
a powerful thing because it relies on
networks of of individuals to be there
the pilot that flies Peter he's got a
whole network of people too or she's got
a whole network of people too how are
you going to convince them to excise
themselves from that reality to support
your kind of fantasy of you know the
wire goes up and you're sitting in the
in the in the Doomsday bunker okay look
that doesn't mean don't prepare for it
but don't freaking delude yourself you
have a network that you're in meshed in
in a project that we call humanity and
you have the benefit of being able to
project those values into the future
through some hard work but making
connections that are durable and I think
that's you know essentially if we're
turning into Lex Friedman podcast you
know final segment that's the meaning of
life you know you have immortality at
your future you can be prepared you can
prepare an infinite network of people
such that if you were to disappear the
network is resilient and it survives I
think that's very powerful and hope
giving even if you don't believe in a
God or believe in this master simulator
or even believe in aliens my thumbs
rather occupied right right now holding
up good old Carl Sean but yours is free
to push that like button and don't
forget to subscribe it really helps us
with the algorithm now back to the
episode for me going back to um the
motivation to prepare and I think maybe
this is where myself and Peter teal and
these other people might have some
similarity it it there's this wisdom I
think in some people right now that the
system is fragile and it becomes
increasingly more as it becomes more
complex it's more prone to
catastrophe and I always use this
metaphor of the island you know like
we're we're on a ship and our our Primal
skills have been left so there's a lot
of people panicking right now because
they've had the realization that without
all of the modern amenities I'd be dead
you know so there's this realization
that the further we go into metaverse
world the the more our natural abilities
atrophy and they almost have this um
crisis point where you realize holy cow
like you know if I was left my own
devices in this world in the cold Forest
I would not survive and I think that
there's this understanding that whatever
Game Theory Game we're playing right now
with you know this arms race or you know
all these crises this group think and
all of these other flaws that we have in
our ability to reason with one another
that it's accumulating into a a
potential disaster of some sort and that
if I'm not prepared um I like to think
that that's that's the most sane way I
can interpret it as opposed to just I
want to live the rest of my life in a
bunker because there is that that
selfishness to preparedness which is
solely individual Focus that you bring
up and that's a good point that you know
preparedness needs to be more Community
focused and there are those groups the
only problem is then you get into the
realm of like culty type behavior and
you know commun and it gets weird right
so I agree with you I like what you say
about ideological children and and then
um you know
potentially I think musk is somewhat
unique in that I think he is pretty big
pitcher in his thinking uh and not
solely just so he can ride out the
Apocalypse in a bunker somewhere by
himself with a shotgun trained on the
door type thing I think he he does you
know genuinely or some of these people
do want to include other people in their
plans but at the end of the day you
can't save everybody and if you know
that this situ this system is doomed of
collaps be it economically due to just
we're going to run out of certain things
uh we're going to eventually reach an
impass with this conflict where there's
going to have to be a nuke fired off
what do you do asides you know prepare
for the inevitable I mean maybe I'm
incorrect in that it's it's not
inevitable and maybe that would be the
flaw in my thinking and I'm willing to
you know I'm always looking for people
to challenge me on those things to say
no you're you're crazy you're just you
know there's no there's no reason for
this but I haven't I haven't really
found any good arguments but I mean you
are and you're not I mean you wouldn't
like to say somebody say it's it's
pointless to prepare right but but um
you know I mean there's a lot of
arguments you could make I'm not saying
I believe in them but you could make an
argument that look once something of a
civilization you know extinction level
event occurs by definition I mean we
just be one of what 15 million different
species that have gone extinct in the
his we're just one out of all those we
happen to be you know kind of attached
to ourselves and think we're pretty
great and we've you know built a lot of
uh you know Snapchats and there's a lot
of Kardashians around but but the point
being how how you know likely is it that
surviving is is a good option you know
it's it's it's and and then it's not not
a small number of people that would
choose I think a suicidal you know
approach rather than live in a
post-apocalyptic world not even like one
on TV just just the sheer isolation you
know the devastation of it the the the
depression uh uh involved in it but I
think you know at at our core you know
our operating system you know if you
think of of you know the physical world
physics and math or the operating system
of the physical world what is the
operating system of the human being well
religious people have have Notions of
that it could be the Quran it could be
the Bible it could be the bhagvat Gita
those are operating manuals that attempt
to give you know kind of object lessons
some some apocryphal some true but I
think there's there's several things
that are you know just just obviously
true and and are self-evident as the
Declaration of Independence would State
you know and that is the pursuit of
happiness and I think you have to really
speculate on what level of Happiness
there could be in such a scenario and so
it is prepping futile of course it's not
because look you got in shape you've
bonded with your kids you've taught them
different lessons uh they they are
resilient they are strong and I think
that's psychological too you actually I
mean we're mammals right we're not just
we're primates we're not just mammals
we're not just organisms we need
physical contact we need in social
interaction and those are you know kind
of our base level realities as well as a
species so um you you know we were
talking earlier like what would the what
would another um an alien civilization
like how would it resemble us and I
think that is some of the use of
thinking about these big picture things
not just like the beginning of the
universe I always say by the way there
like really kind of like four different
Big Bangs if you think about it like the
origin of the Universe from nothing
perhaps uh the which came with the
origin of matter from no matter the
origin of matter then became the origin
of of chemistry and the chemistry became
organized into life that's another kind
of big bang then there's the origin of
technology and and and Consciousness and
thinking for the future and planning for
the future that spatial reasoning and
and constructing technology and
preparing for the future um so those are
different unique things that had to come
into play and the way I like to invert
that is imagine that like let's say
there are eight things Nate let's say
there are eight things that we that had
to happen I think there's probably like
10 to the 50th power things but let's
just say there were eight things okay uh
and there were eight things that needed
to happen for us to have this
conversation right now let's say you
know there had to be a big bang there
had to be you know life existing life
had evolve into into Homo sapiens um
there had to be like a Jupiter sized
planet in the solar system to deflect
these pieces of asteroid and you keep
going and and then you know there's
there hasn't been a you know nuclear war
whatever say there's eight different
things and let's say each each event had
only a probability of one in a thousand
to occur actually think it's it could be
like zero probability let's say it's
it's one part in a thousand take you
know one over a thousand and raise that
to the eighth power that's the only
equation in this whole podcast Nate
right so you get a trillion trillion
that's that's the number that's more
than the number of stars in the
observable universe so now if you ask
you say like on there's one other planet
that had that that means it had to have
all those 10 to the 24 different powers
and that was again assuming this is like
King's Paradox assuming that the the
probability of there being Jupiter and
the probability of there being a big
bang are only one in a thousand in fact
they could be much much smaller than
that or as big as one in a thousand in
fact they're much smaller than that so I
think that connotes the
preciousness the fragility of our
species some people say oh it makes me
feel so you know I don't need a God or
whatever I don't I'm like we're on
borrowed
time this is very precious where we are
it's almost designed I I can see why
people are religious because it seems so
fertile so fac Sun so delightful
designed for our enjoyment you you know
it's not like I was watching you and you
seem to really enjoy the 10-day
challenge like you're eating these this
freeze-dried stuff and you were like you
were like uh I ate worse than this in
college and you said there about seven
Bill six billion people on Earth who
would die to eat this right now you're
absolutely right but did you ever think
like let's go deeper you could actually
get by in just like some some spiralen
and some you know some like some vinam
like it could be very you could eat dog
food I thought about it but even even
more primitive you could just have like
proteins fats and carbohydrate and you
could have like vitamins and just like a
gel that goes into your body that's what
happens when people are in comas right
they don't like serve them beef strog
off we we have a multitude of different
colors we can see multitude of different
flavors a multitude of different people
that we can exist we are living in
paradise and we need to protect it and I
think it might fall to the physicist to
say maybe you know it's you've taken our
inventions you've taken our discoveries
you've led us to the brink of
annihilation on multiple P fronts from
the BIOS sphere from the nucleus of the
of the of the cell to the nucleus of the
atom no more we're not going to play
your silly mind games anymore we're
going to think we're going to be uh
knowledgeable and we're going to act
with wisdom and maybe it'll create some
you know scientific technological Elite
as Eisenhower said everybody knows the
military industrial complex speech Nate
they don't realize in that same speech
he warned of a scientific technological
Elite that would act as I call it an
Academia military complex which is a
subject for another day but let's try to
figure out how we can scale up millions
of people listening to your channel and
Inspire them to protect and conserve the
physical universe that is the only one
that we know exist with the only life
form supporting habitation that we know
exist I believe it's the only one that
does exist that's a subject for another
time um that Harbors technological life
and so for those reasons Nate I think we
should act with great care and concern
but also be hopeful happy optimistic
about the future but preparing for the
worst at the same time I really like how
you summed that up and I know you have
to get going and we're going to have to
touch on some of these issues next time
because we still have a two or three
pages of questions that we haven't got
to but I just wanted to to add to that
and I like how you phrase about you know
this is Paradise this is almost like
we're in the goldilock zone here Cosmic
cosmological speaking and I think
preparedness in a lot of ways it it's
also about self-mastery but it's also
about appreciation for what we have and
it's very I think only a person of the
preparedness mindset of the true
survivalist mindset can
appreciate everything that we have and
that is the reason why we are motivated
to to um try to maintain that standard
of living after afterwards cuz if you
don't appreciate what we have then
you're not going to see any reason to to
better yourself or or you know be
prepared like if you don't truly
appreciate the grid and all its
sophisticated capability then you you're
you're likely you know you're just going
to be like that kid who nothing pleases
them because they've been given every
single thing so you have to go through
and and as you say I'm sorry to
interrupt you but this is a very
powerful thing that you've mentioned
many times you call it the rule of a 100
I believe yeah um I think it's like the
rule of infinity almost so available
right now and and you make this point
and it's but it's true of everything
Nate and what I want to say and applaud
you on that philosophy it's true of
everything not only of getting you know
fresh water and toilet paper tablets and
um you know whatever else we can get at
Canadian preparedness.com uh but it's
true of your relationships too right
imagine God forbid whether you believe
in God or not okay what are your
relationships going to be like they'll
be they'll be there but it'll be like
watch the movie the road as a father and
tell me that doesn't rip your freaking
heart out and I can't spoil a movie
that's 20 years old but people know that
Nate but I'm I'm saying I want to take
your philosophy but apply that to
spirituality and relationships it's a
hundred times easier if not more to
create and nurture
relationships and your philosophy your
mental resilience and I believe you have
a stoic philosophy that lives below its
means in order to prepare and extend for
the future because like you I plan on
spending an awful lot of time in the
future so let's extend the law of 100
but apply to your relationships as well
nurture them while you can tomorrow is
promised to no man